مسلسل وبايدن ترامب لا ينتهي والسبب
السباق الرئاسي نحو البيت الابيض حيث لا
يترك الرجلين اي فرصه للنيل من بعضهما هذه
المره بايدن علق على ترامب بعدما كرر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب اقواله حول
حادثه اقتحام انصاره مبنى الكابيتال في
السادس من يناير عام 2021 في مقابله لشبكه
الان بايدن بدا وكانه يراقب عن كثب خصمه
تراب وغرد ردا عليه قائلا لا انقياء بين
مثيري الشغب انتهت القصه مرفقا هذه
التغريده بمقطع فيديو كما نشاهد هنا
ونصف هذا المقطع لمقابله من ترامب والاخر
للقطات العنف امام مبنى الكابيتول يوم
السادس من يناير في اشاره منه طبعا الى ما
فعله انصار ترامب في ذلك التوقيت وفي ذلك
اليوم ولكن
غير عادته لم يرد ترامب على بايدن ولكن
ثبات مواقفه بشان تزوير نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره والحرب في اوكرانيا خطفت
الاضواء من جديد بعدما اكد مره اخرى انه
سيوقف هذه الحرب خلال اربع انواع وعشرين
ساعه في حال تم انتخابه وانه لن يكون او
لو كان هو رئيسا لما كانت تلك الحرب
اندلعت من اصله وفي حال انتخابه لولايه
جديده سيعمل على تسويه لا يخسر فيها احد
من خلال التفاوض مباشره بين الرئيسين
بوتين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات